hey guys I got a new camera it's a
quality good just check it out before I
started the video
top-tier quality is it good just want to
say welcome to for the first time
there's changes now we're doing fry
Friday's wait no wait sorry
third stage sweet food by Thursday sweet
pea
[Music]
how's it going everyone new camera
doesn't it look good Wow
keep changing the game how does he keep
improving I don't know I just keep
outdoing myself
step by step as you can tell I'm back
in the beautiful can you tell I used to
sit down here basically down there I'm
not on the floor I'm sorry I'm sorry I
thought I'd do a random update video cuz
I haven't I didn't know what to film and
I thought there's a lot of changes like
new camera why is he doing that
what's happening it felt like a good
time okay so grab your favorite G fuel
and let's do this
why am I not on the floor Felix well the
answer might shock you I don't like how
my back hurts from sitting on the floor
it was a good meme I'll probably return
at some point but for now it's nice it
chairs are ok I feel ashamed just saying
that just the way that came out I don't
deserve this tambourine the reason I'm
here again is because I caused a
quarantine basically we're more
comfortable in this location and I
didn't want to pack my camera because
it's huge so I'm using myself a hundred
million subs subscribe please I got a
new camera coming that it's a little
smaller I order one online so don't
worry ok I'm not this is not the
standard even though it should be I mean
look at this it's beautiful looks like a
shitty webcam I've been really enjoying
making videos lately I hope you guys
like them as well and especially doing
the live streams I'm so glad I'm
live-streaming lysa bus check it out
it's so fun we had some great moments
where you guys trolled me
me not remembering what the characters
names are I don't know the interaction
that with the chat and playing a game
has been really fun and it everything
about membership and live streams has
just taken me back to old school to
YouTube where I feel like I'm I have a
closer connection to an audience and
doing laia lets place again which is
something that I've always been very
scared of doing because less place is
such a huge commitment for the channel
there's so many uploads and once you
start one you have to finish it like I
always do I finish all my games and a
lot of times there's a huge disconnect
between your audience and what you enjoy
sometimes games are fun to play but
they're not fun to watch and it's hard
to find games that fit both but I feel
like with live streaming it doesn't
really matter we can just have fun
anyway lots of us a lot of people like
it last of all a lot of people who can
hate it either way it's it's been fun to
play it so I'm really happy about that I
look forward to do more
let's place in the future some more
gaming stuff this channel was originally
a gaming channel that's what I always
seen this channel but it's sort of
progressed and into do all kinds of
different things I feel like I've made
every video possible at this point but
and I always felt awkward like there's
so many people subscribe to this channel
for so many different reasons and I
never know what to do with the gaming
stuff and now I feel like yeah I figure
it out I'll livestream it it'll be
really cool let's see I had some
questions this is like a video I made
like back in 2011 on a shitty webcam I
prepared some questions like the first
riders would PewDiePie hey should we
call this Friday or some PewDiePie let's
yeah hey guys okay Luke asked do you
think you'll do more or less plays like
you're doing Last of Us because I'm
really enjoying the two to three hour
live streams well that yeah yeah
basically yes I've already answered that
goes some tsukushi my next I think after
and terraria of course we're not giving
up on that because I finish all my games
thank you very much
are you going to live go some sushi
Tsushima you yes again looks fun so yeah
I mentioned in a video that very briefly
that me and marks everything
moving to Japan we have a house there
now and due to quarantine we can't go
there there's a lot of different reasons
why I don't really feel like everyone
needs to know every single nuance of
that detail but that's I'm planning
we're planning to go there in the future
sometime whenever we can this is very
very very complicated will you do a
review of the Last of Us part two I
personally would love to hear your
opinion about it when you finish because
your channel got me buying a PlayStation
4 and to play last time whether what
part well that's funny it's such a
polarizing game and it's a god I hate it
so much not not the game at this point I
just hate how people are just losing
their mind over this game either people
are defending it to death like notes you
just hate it because you hate women or
or if you like it then there's something
wrong with you it's like who cares I
think there's a lot there's so much
politics around it and I haven't seen
anyone really discuss it properly but I
need to finish the game first I might do
it afterwards because I think the
politics has a lot of decisions on what
drove the story in terms of personal
decisions but I can only speculate when
are you bringing out more music you
hinted there was something a while ago
but nothing came Wow well me and Dave
have been working for a long time slow
down a bit because of quarantine but
more it is coming I think we have a lot
but we want to make sure it's good so it
might take a while it might take a long
while which i think is fine I but yeah
if I'm not live-streaming it probably
means I'm working on music it's been
really fun I'm glad I'm doing that with
Dave since your streaming partnership
with YouTube happen to me and things
appear to be in good terms is there any
hope for scare PewDiePie season 2 got it
it's been so long ago at this point I'm
just like whatever who knows
Never Say Never right I don't know only
the future can tell I feel like it's
been so dated now that if it came out
now it just it wouldn't even make sense
I think for the sake of people working
on it it would be nice to get a
conclusion but who knows could you do
more vlog like content I think a lot of
people would be interested to have a
peek
to you in Marcel's everyday life well
now during quarantine there's not much
to do every day feels I could say exact
same day I think once we're in Japan
yeah I would definitely love to do that
it's fun for memories too looking back
in old videos it's nice to have that log
so I think what once said this whole
thing is over hopefully soon yeah look
forward today this is a very chill video
how about that a lot of people have been
suggesting I do more philosophy videos
those have probably been my most
requested videos I don't like I can't
just make them hey I need to think about
it because they're so deep I need to sit
down in the forest for a couple hours
for days no it's just that if I have
something random that I feel like I'm
talking about I'll make a video about it
but I can't just decide to do it it just
sort of happens so even though they were
heavily requested which I really really
appreciate because the advice they do
terribly it doesn't matter because I
enjoy making them but I'm also glad that
a lot of people request them has the new
video schedule with brakes worked out
for you both in terms of how the channel
has been doing and how you feel about
recording videos channel is doing great
but I don't know on my day off so I
still tend to work on side projects and
other things like that and it's hard to
like people are already asking about the
music stuff and I shouldn't have said
anything
yeah I'm really bad at taking days off
hey that's on me really it's hard when
you enjoy it so much like in my day off
I would love to stream all day but I
also want to do other things in my life
as well but it's so easy oh I got a
couple hours free I'll go live that kind
of thing which isn't work anyway but I
think the five uploads a week is pretty
good it gives me time to reset the week
instead of everything just flowing into
one thing and I can kind of reflect on
last week what worked what didn't and
give more thought into it even though I
don't but I can if I want to okay geez
are you planning on reviewing or
suggesting any more books in the future
I always find your book videos really
interesting there we go again stop at
home just kidding thank you I'm still
reading just
as avidly as I used to last year or the
year before so I probably won't do the
same format I think I want to make a
video kind of explaining why you should
read kind of like my workout video or
something I don't know I feel like
reading and working out has been the two
best changes I made in my life in terms
of personal growth and feeling good
about myself I feel like everyone should
do it and I want to inspire more people
to do it as well so if I can make that
into a video I think that could be a
really cool thing are you going to take
another break anytime soon I might do
the January meme again honestly I've
been thinking about it
it was really nice I feel like it's fair
any other job you get holidays I don't
really do that and this year especially
has been kind of crazy so yeah I
probably do that in January to be honest
it was good for my mental health I think
they're like my fear is that even if I
enjoy myself I don't want my whole life
to pass by doing the same thing if that
makes sense
even if I love it you know I'm getting
old guys I'm 30 I gotta say I did not
expect me to sit here ten years later
from when I started no [ __ ] way this
is crazy
answering questions things are so
different but still so so much the same
it's kind of crazy what's important
about being a minimalist how to start
things it's funny cuz I sent all my
clothes off to Japan so I had no clothes
I literally you can probably tell I'm
wearing like a black shirt in every
video or my own March I think I talked
about this a little before but I I think
the word means something different for
everyone for me it's just about caring
for the stuff I have I think you can be
the richest person in the world and have
all the items in the world but if you
don't care for what you have and you
have too much of it you're not gonna
appreciate it and I think that's just
the mentality to be thankful for what
you have to me at least I remember you
know Mark Zuckerberg wears the same
shirts every day and he said it it was
because he he needs to make a lot of
decisions in that way he doesn't have to
deal with it and that sounded so stupid
when I heard
but but now someone in my position that
gets so many questions every single day
that it's definitely real like the
fatigue of answering even small stuff
like stupid questions like that are nice
I'm still I can't deal with it sometimes
and Here I am answering questions how
ironic I think it's just being there in
the position I am people want things
from me all the time which is fine but
it just gets hard to keep up booooo-whoo
me
I know opinions on ninja and scare
situation if any I have not heard about
this and I'm very glad I haven't cuz I'm
so [ __ ] tired of people's [ __ ] I
don't care like so I don't know what
this is about but it's like someone's
someone you is getting cancer all every
day today the earth is dying it don't
matter what does your new setup look
like that is a great question I'll show
a picture actually even better I can
literally just move this one camera can
I look at that yes I'm playing tat
Titans sue me this is my portable setup
basically fits in a suitcase it's
alright it works that's all he needs to
do it works any plans of dropping shoes
ooh who knows who knows wink wink wink
how are you doing these days oh why
thank you for asking
I'm doing really good I'm so happy I
feel like I finally came in terms with
myself realized not everything will
always be perfect you just got to be
happy with where you are I'm in a good
place anyway so I have every reason to
be but there's something I thought about
especially with all the drama that goes
on online there's always a new drama a
new topic and people just like small
things seems to be so big online and it
makes me feel like people are just
miserable like this is this is important
to you really it makes me feel bad I
feel like if I could change one thing
there were people to just be happier
because then people wouldn't get so
worked up over these insignificant
things all the time like people that
don't like Last of Us for example it's
like and and harassing the people that
made it I find it so baffling you start
going to be a co Kamel and dis track
yes the thing is I don't want it to fall
in the same meme as t-series where it
went too far even though I don't think
that was my fault I just don't want to
fall in the same thing if anything the
only mistake I made was to not kind of
end it sooner it's just for fun
literally a fun meme but I think it
could be a funny video so yeah well I
collaborate with mr. beast yeah I think
we talked about doing something together
at some point we do live very far away
so we'll see do you have to clarify you
are joking every time you make an NG
joke clearly yeah I do people think
clearly take jokes out of context as
weapons against them so yeah I feel like
I really have to it's super stupid but
that's the world we live in it is what
it is we need closet review okay I'll
film it it's coming up right now where's
my closet are you guys impressed wow
it's so dark this is not lit up there we
go
it's IKEA built it myself
designed it myself the layout on the
online IKEA thing measured it yeah it's
pretty epic here or here underwear socks
always have the same brand of socks do
not have different brands of socks
biggest life hack of all time saving
underwear they're the same brand because
your junk and your feet needs to feel
the same way every day never wear
different socks because otherwise they
get lost in laundry you're welcome
saved your life my pack isn't that
writing here oh sorry I got Jesus
t-shirt these are all my t-shirts that's
it that's my closet I have no other
clothing except these pants and these
paints and that's all you need baby
closet tour done you're welcome do you
like golf as much as aadmi I actually do
play golf I played a ton as a kid I
think my handicap was like 17 which
isn't it's decent I have a really good
swing actually I'm pretty proud of it I
just like the focus my dad is really
good at golf we played last time he was
over in UK was really fun do you ever
consider
retiring from YouTube I think I did more
last year but after my break it kind of
gave me some time to understand which
part of it I'll enjoy and that I just
want to focus on that it's crazy to
think how you entertained so many people
on a daily basis but how do you imagine
the long-term future of current YouTube
are you planning on learning YouTube
until you're very old or what do you
think you move on something new at some
point we have to think how many
youtubers now we now watch will be 50
sometime in the future bro well like I
said earlier I didn't expect to even be
making videos now so anything is a bonus
I'll take you
yeah I remember a few years ago hearing
someone was 30 and did the YouTube is
like what dude you're too old for this I
think it's changing YouTube is changing
it's gonna keep changing you never know
what's gonna happen and that's part of
the fun I think I can't answer this
question to be honest I think it's gonna
be similar to TV stars or TV or things
like that longer careers exist it's just
how it is be honest are you actually
enjoying thinness and ferb or is
something that feels forced I enjoyed
them it's been really fun to watch them
during the live streams if you can in
case you didn't know we watched one
episode at the end of each live stream
it's not my favorite cartoon but I enjoy
that you guys enjoyed so much I think I
prefer gumball more to be honest sorry
Phineas and Ferb fans if I had to watch
a cartoon out I would probably watch a
gumball are you reading any interesting
books at the moment that you would like
to make a video by I really enjoy it
here we go again book book book I'm
almost done with the sword and
chrysanthemum it's really interesting
but also been reading The Odyssey are
you ever planning on modded minecraft
Eric's there are so many mods that
amplified the game so much no but we
have our members only minecraft server
coming up really soon it's almost done I
think I hope I'm not working on it
so I look forward for that hopefully I
get a chance to play with you guys as
well I think that about wraps it up
doing good
hope you guys are doing well as well
thank you for watching the videos
hopefully this was okay I see you next
time hey don't cut it all
ramen n we say so professed pouring yeah
Friday repairman
hey I said it I said the word ha ha
you haven't played super simulator on
the beach good
pack your bags and sit down no one wants
to see your face max 10 lines anyway
download super simulator for the perfect
beach body